hello it's andrew steven and adam just
wanted to give you a heads up that this
episode was filmed at the beginning of
the year before we began social
distancing due to covet 19. we are
currently practicing social distancing
but we wanted to share these great
restaurants with you even the dining out
is not the same
right now all right we're in the good
zone alrighty
worth it season eight for those who are
counting season seven
was dumpling all the way to fried
chicken sandwich
we're gonna call that season seven so
now we have a new set of six episodes
that's season eight what you're watching
right now that's right uh
it feels pretty bright on my head is
that okay
moon roof new highlander
[Music]
[Music]
first episode of the season stephen take
it away
today on worth it we're going to be
trying three pancakes at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one
is the most worth it at its price so
we're starting with a breakfasty pancake
then we'll be having a crunchy lunchy
pancake
and then we're gonna have actually a
dinner pancake
i don't want to skim over the highlight
of what you just said which is
brunchy lunchy brunchy limestone you've
never heard that before and that is one
of the greatest things i've ever heard
first pancake the og oatmeal griddle
cake
at breakfast by saltscare we're going to
be talking to chef chris
about how it's made hold on to your
pants for this because
they don't serve maple syrup at this
restaurant listen this is a
bold play by them syrup is usually the
reason people consume
pancakes so for sure it's a big move
it's challenging it's low-key maddening
breakfast by salzburg is a quick service
breakfast restaurant but
we specialize in pancakes we're really
proud of the pancakes so we put that
first front and center we feature
oatmeal griddle cakes which are like
pancakes but they have the texture and
flavor from
oats a single is if you just need a
little bit
the full order there's three and it's
like
medicine for your soul really but it's
all a la carte you want sausage you want
potatoes
the idea behind sausage and not bacon
it's like kind of a zero waste
philosophy so
there's only so much bacon on each pig
the whole thing can be made into sausage
so it's more affordable
for the guests to get quality
handcrafted products the griddle cake
was my mom's
recipe so it's near and dear to my heart
i had it when i was 18 months
old when my teeth were still tender
still i remember it it was amazing
that day so it doesn't need syrup
because it has some sweetness to it
in fact you don't serve syrup here is
that right yeah we are
anti syrup and why is that like my mom
served it with
just cinnamon and sugar just a thin
sprinkle of each one
with some butter i don't know when i
have syrup on it it clashes a little bit
there's something wrong
the condiment for the og is butter with
molasses
and sugar and cinnamon mixed into it it
melts
and has a similar syrupy quality
a lot of customers are like no i need
syrup and they're like never mind
it's good
what a perfect way to start the season
breakfast
cheers whoa
without a little rusty that's right
okay steven whoa one griddle cake for
each of us
look at the outline yeah also
i love proportion to plate it just makes
it feel
like it's in your face like bam
proportion to plate ratio the pp ratio
yeah i like that cheers
oh totally not what i was expecting it
almost has the texture
of like a potato pancake crispy on the
top
and still custardy in the center this
pancake is actually delivering the role
of a full breakfast in one item tell me
how
pancake check hash browns that texture
of hash browns
is achieved with the outside crust of
this pancake
oatmeal okay it owed batter
check cooked on a griddle like eggs
yeah i see it's a multifaceted item
oatmeal pancake i understand now i could
really eat that pancake every day
we'll be moving on to our next meal of
the day pancakes soon but before that
pancake bag the essential idea of the
pancake is not just
ancient it's prehistoric scientists and
historians have analyzed starch grains
on
30 000 year old grinding tools that
could suggest that during the stone age
people were making flower-like mixtures
out of cattails and ferns
researchers hypothesized that they were
making these on a hot
greased rock a hot greased rock that's
right the original pan
for pancakes might as well call these
rock cakes
okey dokey so we went for our breakfast
pancake now we're going for our brunchy
lunchy pancake at a place called all day
baby and we're going to be having their
hot hotcake we're going to see chef
jonathan we actually featured previously
on the show
during our toast episode that's right it
was over right here's looking at you
and he opened a brand new restaurant all
day baby so
again it's something that's not
technically called a pancake but when
you see this you'll see it's it's
in the pancake family we're having a
brunchy
lunchy all day baby hot cake
[Music]
good to see you again meet you guys can
you just tell us a little bit about this
restaurant so all day baby is like a
upscale diner the best way i try to
explain to people is i created a
restaurant where i want to hang out and
eat it i'm a big barbecue fan i like
breakfast food i like
crazy like delicious pastries and
milkshakes and booze so it's like
it all together into like one thing and
like it's like pretty much like a
collective of like just everything i
grew up eating you know my dad's from
the south with the barbecue stuff and
there's a little bit of the latin flips
my mom's side all that jazz it's like
all together
there's things you recognize but
everything has a little bit of a flair
to it all day baby
it's a heavy proposition yeah to say all
day it's like i would not want to brand
myself
all day because i'm like i can maybe
give you like half a day
not all day and today we're trying your
pancakes it's not technically a pancake
but it's
the hot cake so pancakes you know you
griddle them so they're usually
individual thin little pancakes
ours is baked so it's like pretty thick
what we do is we we take a buttermilk
pancake batter
once it hits the pan we put it in the
pan and not on the griddle so it's a lot
of oil
put the batter in when you're like first
initially cooking it you know the pan
has to be pretty decently hot
bring it up really fast with the batter
in it so like it gets that crust on the
bottom
it's temperamental they have to put it
in the oven just the right time if they
didn't set it right it doesn't
rise properly you know it's a diner so
everything's heavy we use the term
[ __ ]
just putting more on top of it so it's
like let's put really rich ricotta on
top of it let's put blueberry jam on top
and let's put
pistachios on it just like building more
fat on top i look at food and like
the main ingredient is mainly just the
vessels that bring sauce to your mouth
that's like what we do with everything
here when we first got in here we were
just kind of like messing with the smoke
and we just started smoking everything
to see what would come out we thought of
the idea of just testing out the maple
and seeing how that would come out and
it really absorbed the flavor really
well and it helps it's just another
dimension at it because it's like i
wanted to use the smoker as much as i
could to incorporate in the dishes it's
like you can't really like
you can't throw the hot cake in there
and smoke it would be weird but uh you
know the maple
worked really well what are we calling
this brunch or lunch
all day baby i'm so glad chef suggested
we try these sweet teas
my favorite cocktail it's on right now
is the sweet tea which is like their
play on a long island
with the santori whiskey and the toppo
chico and the mango sweet tea it's
really good but this sounds delicious
cheers wow that's really good
having a glass of iced tea thank you
thank you
yeah it looks like cornbread i'm ready
to eat it's hot so we're going to go
sands
syrup the grapes cheers
[Music]
very nutty very nutty very nutty
surprisingly
and pleasantly not very sweet what is
that flavor of the pig
it doesn't cake it's like a little more
fried
rather than griddle yes right like
tastes a little bit deep fried
like the exterior of a corn dog maybe
yes
smell that this smoky
maple it smells so good
it smells meaty all right smoked syrup
oh my goodness
oh oh my god that is so
tasty that's my new favorite flavor it
is right
on the line of savory and sweet
that's the smoke 100
yeah it's very meaty since we're all day
baby and this is our
lunch pancake i think we should have a
little bit more lunch
and uh try one of their sandwiches the
beef and cheese is a sirloin that we
smoke and then slice
rare and then put it with the toasted
brioche with the cheese sauce nobody
wants to admit that they like rvs but
everyone likes the beef and cheese at
arby's i know video
yeah it's like it's like that dirty
thing that people don't like to admit to
and that's like i want to just make
one better thank you oh my goodness
thank you
this what it looks
like those food mock-ups in japanese
restaurants
yeah of how perfect it is and how the
cheese melted
bon voyage
didn't know how bad i needed that you
know you've had a good meal when you
assumed this posture i i
actually feel weird
[Laughter]
this is the most adam sandwich that ever
existed
pancake fact
okay steven you ready for this pancake
fact i've been ready all day baby all
right this is actually going to be a
pancake fact quiz in ancient greece and
rome
they ate a form of pancakes that were
sweetened with what
yeah how many guesses do i get you get
one sugar rock sugar
incorrect maple syrup incorrect honey
correct
i mean you didn't get it because you
only had one guess it's actually weird
when you think about
how there's all this sweet stuff that
oozes out of things naturally in the
world we've got syrup coming out of
trees
honey from not sure what bees are doing
to it but
uh every fruit in existence i don't know
what happens with molasses but
something's happening there okay where
are we going to next
now it's time for our evening pancake so
this pancake is at
a seafood restaurant we're on our way to
see chef joshua
at angler we're having what is actually
a
caviar course and the caviar is served
with a banana pancake if you're thinking
that okay they're just going to eat
expensive caviar
and that's why it's the third stop no
this is an insane pancake
this pancake utilizes every aspect
of the banana okay i'm ready to eat this
caviar
sorry pancake
i was hoping you could just tell us what
type of restaurant angler is
i think most of the focus is just sea
life but more kind of esoteric species
that are smaller fisheries smaller
vessels
using more sustainable methods to catch
fish and see life is
you know obviously a better choice the
hearth is your creation right what if
you could speak a little bit about the
motivation of that
well fire's been one of our guiding
ethos for a long time i think it just
tastes better so the fire is always
burning then yeah
maybe in my heart you know there's a few
kind of standard things that we always
do in all our restaurants
get a good product utilize you know 100
of that product so zero waste
and so in this case we have a banana the
meat of bananas mix in two different
ways to the pancakes you got the world
meat itself
and they have the chips which we
dehydrate over the fire and turn into a
powder
if you put just banana in there then it
gets too soft and
falls apart you can see these racks that
we have back there we move those around
depending on the level of heat that we
want and the level of time that we're
going to stick in the fire
so the peels you just stick there until
they they basically barbecue
you know it slowly perfumes over time it
becomes kind of a deep
flavor once they're ready we just infuse
them in the butter and what's the rough
time frame for that couple days
couple days you do a full day yeah
that's representative of
how we would do you know most dishes
let's not add anything
to it right until we figure out how to
utilize 100 of the product right
and then from there once it tastes its
best then we can start adding things to
it so in this case just a little maple
syrup and caviar all the people that
watched this show
have never tried caviar before and they
don't know what that flavor is like and
describe what this caviar tastes like
caviar when it's bad is just a very like
salty rancid fish fat flavor
this is the exact opposite of that where
it's just like savory no it's not too
salty
it's got a little bit of saline in it so
it's oceanic right it's like the deep
ocean rather than or like a clean river
that banana flavor
with caviar though what why does that
work well it's sweet you have sweet and
salty
we use just a taste balance scale so the
taste balance counts you try to be as
objective as possible so
let's say you put a whole dish in your
mouth there shouldn't be any corners
right so the
the taste balance should be pretty
circular and so you'll start with one
flavor it'll continue on to another and
then
another and then another and then it
starts over again right
is this a pancake dish or is this a
caviar dish to me it's a pancake dish i
think a lot of people's caviar dish but
you can have it for whatever you want it
for i understand we eat this pancake
with our hands
why is that i think with most things you
do with your hands you get to feel the
texture of it a little bit right
your fingers give you a feedback loop
and you start to feel part of that not
only in your in your mouth but in your
hands so
i don't want people to have anything but
a good time that's really what it's all
built for it's just experience design so
people have fun
does this look like a place you'd
normally eat a pancake no
you've got a golden cart that rolls out
to your table you have a little grill
that we put some embers in and the
pancakes go in there so they stay hot
right the last second of the table
and then the service team takes a
pancake puts on a plate
lathers it with the barbecued banana
peel butter and then puts a giant
dollop of caviar on top roughly about an
ounce per pancake
gentlemen please enjoy thank you i'm
speechless
it seems wacky but the process for
making this thing
every part of the banana its days of
labor
also the caviar which is made
specifically for them to be paired with
a banana pancake is this is just fun i
feel like you know i know
it's thoughtful but dare i say almost
logical
like this is maybe the only way that it
should be done
whoa okay i'm not gonna delay no delay
all right
oh my goodness cheers i wanna cheers
this
wow holy smokes
the best part of this dish may have been
the pancake it's a hundred percent the
pancake what do you think about banana
plus
caviar why does it work i think it is
kind of
like tropical i feel like i'm on you
feel like i'm
on a an island and i'm eating bananas
off the tree
and fish out the water i am confused at
how like
wrong and right this is like what could
not go on this banana pancake you know
my actual favorite part of this is tell
me eating a pancake with your hands
i think this is the only way to eat a
pancake it just hit me that that was
happening yeah what have you ever eaten
a pancake with your hands
so this is a pancake episode is this an
excellent pancake no doubt i don't know
if we did justice on how good this
is i don't know how to communicate that
it's more banana flavor than i've ever
tasted in a bite and yet it's
a really delicious caviar dish
that concludes episode one of season
eight pancake
what an adventure yeah season eight off
to a strong start
stephen what was your favorite thing
that was not a pancake
i am still thinking about the orange
juice that i
drank at breakfast health care that is
so
really good orange juice my favorite
thing that was not a pancake was just
the overall decor at angler we got
fish on the walls the little monkey bowl
holding the
banana butter and the blankets on the
back of
every chair it sounds like you spent a
lot of time looking around at an angler
but we're here for one thing and one
thing only that people want to know
which pancake what's the most worth it
to you at a given price point take it
away
i'm gonna go with all day baby because
the smoked maple syrup
was a transcendent experience for me
great pancake you're wrong
well then what was your worth at winter
the banana pancake at
angler like that is a story i would tell
my kids about i would tell my mom my
kids
my wife my dad adam it was the poetry of
the pancake breakfast by salt's cure
that pancake
i will say after we ate it i was like
this is over end the video
but then more things happened and here
we are
talking about poetry one more question
adam who is you're worth it winner
adam says angler the banana pancake with
i win all right so that was episode one
got some really exciting stuff what's
next
here we go the next episode of worth it
rhymes with rice
no it is rice
[Music]
you